[Music]
it's a tick tock battle of the trends
kim kardashian and northwest versus
kourtney kardashian and penelope disick
yep on wednesday the 41 year old kkw
beauty founder joined her eight-year-old
daughter on the social media platform to
lip sync along to a song called jenny by
studio killers it's always so much fun
[Music]
not bad right i don't know how you're
going to top that well kim's older
sister court and her nine-year-old
daughter did the trend first writing
alongside it quote we cannot keep a
straight face
[Music]
of course court and p launched their own
tick tock account back in november
and shortly after kim and north followed
suit
why not
[Music]
you just gotta roll with it but this is
hardly the first time they've tackled
the same trend going for it and like
having no fear kim and quartz girls both
screamed into the camera before
revealing their outfit of the day
and they put their own spin on the trend
where you bob your head before revealing
friends and family bobbing their head
along with you
penelope and north both showed off their
kicks to the sound of nancy sinatra's
these boots are made for walk-ins
and while north got the assist from her
little sis chicago rapping eminem
penelope recruited her famous mom
[Music]
penelope and north have both made
special appearances on each other's
accounts
[Music]
everybody running out the room
everybody begging go soon
and they've both managed to get their
moms to dance on the platform it's
really lit and fun and crazy
holy spirit activate activate activate
even though kim famously claims she
doesn't dance i'm like a notorious
non-dancer like it's a
[Music]
not too shabby kim thank you
of course the skim's founder is the
queen of social media you know social
media is such a great tool i mean she
basically invented the selfie you just
take about 500 pictures until you get
the right one and back in 2018 she
opened up to et about the biggest lesson
she's learned from being online i think
if you have any questions about it don't
share it i'm never not proud of anything
that i
have shared but at the time it might
be something that i was so excited to
post and now i could look back and be
like well i might not post that today
but i have like no regrets at that time
i was really feeling it so just don't be
impulsive think it through think about
if you want people to know this
information because it'll always be
there and that will never change but you
need boundaries i think everyone does
well one thing is for sure north and
penelope are following in kim's
footsteps and crushing it
[Music]